[Music]
today we're going to give you a very
quick talk on bigquery GIS so looking at
the agenda we'll give you a very brief
introduction into bigquery GIS so what
exactly is it and some of the data types
around it and then we will spend the
bulk of the time giving you guys a demo
so showcasing the features and showing
you some of the example use cases you
have three speakers today canna tin and
myself Rachel we are all strategic cloud
engineers based in the London office
okay
so big cream for those that do not know
bigquery is Google Cloud Data enterprise
data warehouse it can manage large data
so we manage storage on the petabyte
scale and you can run analysis on up to
billions and billions of births you can
interact with bigquery using SQL and
it's fully managed and Cerberus so you
don't have to worry about spinning up
clusters and managing resources that's
all done for you the idea that you load
your data run your analysis it's super
big it's super quick so then we move on
to bigquery GIS so G is is geospatial
information systems and bigquery is one
of the first cloud providers to offer an
MPP massively parallel processing data
warehouse that supports geospatial
functions and data types so we have the
concept of a geography data type and
that's essentially a point set on the
Earth's surface and when you combine
that with your location data in your
bigquery table so for example if you
have longitude latitude or country codes
you can essentially derive really
powerful insight it makes your data a
lot more relatable underpinning this all
is the same library used in Google Maps
and we also have the bigquery geo
visualization tool which is the
lightweight tool that allows you to view
your analysis against a live map so I
mentioned the geography data type and I
said this represents a point set on the
Earth's surface
so by point set this can be an actual
like a point on the surface or a set of
points so a line string or a polygon and
we'll see this in action in the demo you
also have GIS functions and types and if
you're familiar with post GIS you'll be
familiar with this and these essentially
just operate on the durable feed data
type enough talking I think let's hand
over to Connor who will do a demo and
show you some of these features and
actually
okay hi welcome everyone so I'm doing a
demo of like the data types and the
functions that are available within my
query GIS so this like we are starting
with a blank slate so on the left side
you have the query and on the right side
you have the map so this is like a
visualization tool as part of my query
so it's it's called bigquery geo vez so
what we are doing now is basically we
are starting from scratch so we are
drawing a point of where we are so we
are in Moscone Center
so the function we use is st underscore
geocoin and we provide the Latin long so
as you can see we have the Moscone
Center on the right so yeah this is one
point now we are going to draw one more
point so this is the baseball stadium
Oracle park so it as you can see like
the st underscore geocoin takes like two
parameters the longitude first and then
the latitude just the convention so what
you see now is basically you have like
both the points using the Union all
method and now we are going to connect
both the points using st underscore make
line and I do Union all again so that I
display the line and the two on the two
points okay now we are going to draw a
like a polygon of three points using
Google s of office it's the Third Point
and what we use here is s T and s could
make polygons and yeah and we use the G
objects function and then we draw a
polygon okay once we have the polygon
now we can do all the other measures
like distance perimeter and so on so
what I've shown here is the centroid
what you're seeing now is basically the
public data sets that are available
within bigquery so what it's the one
that is shown here is basically the bike
data set the Ford go bike so these are
the bike stations that are available so
as we can see there are like three
clusters so this is one this is the
cluster in San Francisco so all the bike
now so these are all the bike stations
now let's filter to only the bike
stations that are within that specific
polygon using the function st underscore
within s T stands for like special types
which is a common terminology in in geo
a so as you can see there's also like a
straight view so I just clicked on one
of the points and as you can see you can
see the Ford go bike station with the
bikes
so this is like a complex polygon so
it's basically the zip code so you can
get the zip code data set your zip code
data set from the beaker a public data
sets
so what we see now here is
so this is like all the bike stations
so
yeah this is like the cluster of points
so what this cluster represents is the
size of the circle represents the number
of bikes that are available within that
specific bike station so if the circle
is bigger which means that there are a
lot of bikes and if it's smaller
it means it's a less number of bikes and
what we're going to see now is basically
from Moscone within a 500 meter radius
what are the bike stations that are
available so these are all some of the
bike stations that are available within
a 500 meter distance finder meter radius
so as you can see there is one very
close by in front of like the Whole
Foods just right outside okay so as you
can see it's like very easy to actually
do all these like basic methods and data
types so you can start using it to do
very complex geospatial functionalities
thank you thanks kind of okay so for my
demo I'm going to talk about how you can
use some of the functionalities we
discuss for analysis for fun and profit
keeping with the cyclo higher data set
I'm going to move across the Atlantic to
London where we base I'm going to also
take the view of the operator of the
psych Ohio service so as operator I want
to know what do people use the cycle
service for and I like by drawing the 50
most common path that's taken by my
service I can see that most of the path
is happening around hi Park so hi Park
is a big station is a big park in
central London that's very popular with
tourists what this tells me is that
people are using the service quite a lot
for tourism so looking at the previous
analysis I can see that some stations
are more frequently used as the
destination ie more bikes arrived for
that station than there are bikes
starting from that station so if the
this may cause some capacity problems
if I am a Taurus arriving at the station
that's very frequently used I might not
find a docking station so I want to do
some analysis of this trend what I've
done here is I've counted a number of
trips that started at the station and
subtracted it from the number of trips
that ending at that station and plotted
on the map
red means there are more trip starting
from that station and blue means there
are more trips ending at that station
looking at the station with the biggest
disparity I can see that corresponds to
hop exchange to borrow which is where I
know there's a big farmers market that's
also very popular with tourists so with
this knowledge I can start making some
changes to accommodate for this trend
this also make me ask the question do
people use this cycle service for
commute at all so by isolating the trips
two hours in the morning versus evening
commute I can immediately see a trend
where in the morning mostly people are
using the service to commute into
central London and vice versa and
evening this is most pronounced at Kings
Cross station which you might have heard
from Harry Potter it's also a big
communal spot where for everybody
outside of London commuting in so
personally I also like to go to Borough
Market in the weekend I know that I
won't be able to dock my bike there it's
a very common destination so what I can
do is I can find the ten closest station
nearby and immediately I can see that
the closest station is Park Street Bank
side which is about 164 meters away
thank you thank you just to quickly wrap
up hopefully you guys have seen how you
can harness big data with GIS to derive
insights and make your data a bit more
relational don't take our word for it we
have a few links on the slides where you
can go and have a play it's currently in
beta but as you've just seen there's
about you can play with them familiarize
yourself with thank you so much for
attending and for listening
[Music]